hi this is John how are you hi would you
be able to give me an update right now
are you still in Tahrir my name is John
Scott wrelton I am a third year doctoral
student and the Department of urban
planning which is where we're sitting
where in my little student office my
relationship to Egypt is that I began
going to Egypt first is a kind of a
tourist but really to see friends I had
been following the events in Egypt
through Twitter then something happened
the internet went down the Egyptian
government cut Twitter I decided through
a kind of last minute thing just as
eventually this office I have contacts
in Egypt I can call these people and I
can return Twitter to an information
function I reached out to people who i
knew and friends of friends and got
phone numbers i began calling those
phone numbers and getting people to talk
to me and then tweeting what they said
within the first seven hours of doing
this i was told that the mobile phones
were going to be shut down and so i
switched to calling landlines what i do
is i call someone part of a growing
network of people who are known to me or
who are known to people I trust this way
I could have some confidence that I'm
not talking to we could say virtual
people and when I can i record what they
have to tell me and then I post that
recording online hello Ali can I just
record you telling me exactly what
you're doing really fast I'm just a
person on the street can we do that
right now ok and in three two one you
are go I don't think I'm doing that good
a job of what I'm doing my recording
consists of putting a blackberry on top
of my laptop on speakerphone I can't
move very
than I wish I could make a hundred calls
an hour and I think it's a testament to
the desire of these different people to
reach out and talk to each other that
this is any kind of a success my stuff
is hosted in three different places on
youtube on twitter which is Jen 25 it's
a channel of audio that I'm posting and
right now I have 3.5 million unique
plays for that audio and so we can see
each one of the things has the place
we've got 1.6 million where we have
another dictator 1.6 million an Egyptian
executive some don't get a lot of
attention 279 plays seven hundred and
five players part of this story is that
i was a consumer of information and
within a day i was able to switch from a
consumer into a producer and i did that
because you had two populations one in
egypt and one in the united states and
the rest of the world and they wanted to
talk to each other and what the Egyptian
government did was try to cut quite
literally that high bandwidth connection
between those two peoples during this
critical time every year in Egypt if you
go back decades somebody had called for
a general strike every year in Egypt
there were small protests but the police
always responded with a massive presence
the difference this year is that the
police responded with a massive presence
but so did everyone else and they did it
because they were telling each other
strangers and friends through Twitter
come now we've got numbers every
movement finds its tactics and I think
what we've seen is that this movement
has found its own and when you have that
Concilium on trains and a set of tools
that are powerful and potent ways for
them to communicate to each other and to
communicate to the outside world
especially as what the outside world
thinks from a moment to on the basis is
growing ever more important then you
have a real potential for change part of
me thinks that this will not be the last
story coming out of the Middle East in
the next year or two it has a texture
like this Egypt's politics broke my
heart every year I love the country and
I love
people but I didn't think that I would
be doing us and it's a testament to what
this story is that i was able to
actually reach in and help and it would
not have been possible without social
media
take good care of my friend not give me
a lot thicker